mitte september wird die raumsonde
cassini in die atmosphäre des saturns
stürzen und dort verglühen ein
spektakuläres ende mit explosionen doch
bis dahin steht noch so einiges auf der
to do liste von cassini alle wichtigen
infos zur casinis finale und wie ihr
absturz genau ablaufen wird jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
die schwierigsten herausforderungen gab
es bei der cassini mission noch vor
ihrem start bei 197 mehrmals stand das
projekt ja auf der kippe mit insgesamt
mehr als drei milliarden dollar war es
den usa zu teuer und wurde immer wieder
in frage gestellt aber dann am 15
oktober 1997 startete eine der
ehrgeizigsten missionen der menschheit
damals wog die sonde 5700 kilogramm also
fast sechs tonnen mehr als die hälfte
des gewichts machte der treibstoff aus
und drei tonnen molekül hydrazin und als
oxidationsmittel also damit brennt die
stickstoffdioxid nach rund 1,5
milliarden kilometern und sechs jahren
war sie dann endlich in der umlaufbahn
des saturns angekommen der länder
ruhiges wurde auf dem unwirtlichen mond
titan abgesetzt und konnte sogar 72
stunden lang daten senden zum ersten mal
konnten so bilder von titan gemacht
werden
die dichte atmosphäre verhinderte dass
bis dahin der größte erfolg der mission
bisher auf dem saturnmond enceladus
wurden bedingungen für mögliches
außerirdisches leben entdeckt dafür von
führte die saturnsonde ein absolut
spektakuläres manöver
sie verbrachte ein kunststück für das
sie eigentlich gar nicht vorgesehen war
2005 entdeckte die sonne ja aktive
geysire auf dem saturnmond enceladus
danach wurde die komplette mission
verändert die instrumente an bord wurden
umprogrammiert und cassini flug sieben
mal durch die fontänen am südpol von
enceladus cassini lieferte noch mehr ab
beispielsweise qualitativ hochwertige
bilder von venus jupiter und natürlich
den saturnmond und ringen sowie viele
spannende daten zu deren zusammensetzung
wenn man es genau nimmt konnten
überhaupt 7 saturnmonde erst durch die
von cassini gelieferten daten entdeckt
werden seit april dieses jahres hatte
die nasa-sonde mit den tauchgängen durch
die saturnringe begonnen dabei sind wir
wirklich faszinierende aufnahmen
gelungen wir haben es geschafft hatte
die nasa am 27 april getwittert und das
war wirklich ein sensationeller erfolg
die raumsonde war in völlig unerforscht
terror gelang catania hatte sich der
wolkendecke von saturn auf bis zu 3000
kilometer gen er so nah wie nie zuvor
ihre krassen manöver in den bis dahin
unerforscht gebieten zwischen saturn und
seinen inneren ringen werden wohl so
schnell nicht vergessen werden
doch jetzt geht die reise zu ende der
treibstoff von cassini also sie drei
tonnen sind aufgebraucht und die nasa
hat beschlossen diese mission zu beenden
und zwar gezielt damit die sonde nicht
unkontrolliert crash denn das risiko bei
dem crash saturnmonde mit mikroben von
der erde zu kontaminieren also zur
verunreinigung dieses risiko ist im
forschungsteam viel zu hoch denn wir
haben ja hier schon öfter darüber
berichtet dort könnte eben eventuell
leben existieren dass es noch zu
erforschen gilt und das ging nicht mehr
so gut wenn ein mond kontaminiert wurde
und der erste schritt zum kontrollierten
absturz von cassini ist bereits getan
ihre flugbahn ist so abgelenkt dass sie
in den saturn führt wo sie dann mitte
september auch für immer goodbye sagen
wird aber wir sagen gibt es noch so
einiges für sie zu tun daten sollen
gesammelt und aufnahmen gemacht werden
zum beispiel weitere bilder vom saturn
system mit seinen monden titan und
enceladus und auch von der leuchtenden
saturn aura die nasa teams erhoffen sich
zudem noch weitere details zu den
temperaturen und den wirbeln an den
polen des planeten am 9 september wird
cassini dann laut nasa informationen
knapp 1700 kilometer über den höchsten
wolken des saturns das letzte mal
zwischen ihm und seinen ringen hindurch
tauchen 48 stunden später wird sie dann
den titan passieren bevor sie
schließlich laut plan am 14 september
die finale datenübertragung zur erde
startet sie endet dann einen tag später
spektakulär für den 15 september ist das
ende geplant
um punkt 1353 mitteleuropäischer
sommerzeit beginnt ihr eintritt in die
atmosphäre
1500 zehn kilometer hoch über den wolken
würze den kontakt zur erde verlieren
auseinanderbrechen und verglühen wie ein
meteor doch cassini soll noch bis zu
ihrer letzten sekunde senden würde der
plan der nasa bei ihrem absturz sollen
letzte aufschlussreiche daten über
radiowellen an die erde gesendet werden
und im besten fall spannende details zur
saturnatmosphäre liefern nach spätestens
zwei minuten wird der kontakt wohl aber
abbrechen mehr als 3,2 milliarden dollar
hat die mission der nasa esa die
italienische raumfahrtagentur asi und
weiteren beteiligten auch aus
deutschland dann gekostet mitte
september
die dann nicht nur für cassini alles zu
ende auch für tausende mitarbeiter aus
mehr als 17 ländern endet ein wichtiges
kapitel auch wenn es noch zahlreiche
daten von cassini gibt die ausgewertet
werden wollen aber darüber werden wir
hier dann natürlich berichten wenn ihr
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
würden wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit sensations- von staub
aus dem interstellaren raum auch eine
cassini entdeckung sehr sehr spannend
nicht verpassen und draufklicken würde
ich mal sagen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran